guys I saw um killers of the flower Moon
oh how was that
horrible the whole time no distractions
three and a half hours in a theater I
mean it I tried really hard to not be
distracted but I couldn't sit through it
three and a half hourss is tough three
and a half hours in a theater the movie
could be an hour and a half long M
easily there's no point to it sha too
you can ask sh yeah it's not a good
movie and it's also so obviously like Po
Cup this is like this is like score what
what say poppy [__] what does that mean
poy Baler Dash oh oh
damn what the
hell familiar synonyms please that crazy
nonsense I thank you okay so to me this
is the movie all right I'm Martin scy I
do really well when I do uh Mob stuff I
ran out of Italians to do it with I ran
out of Irish to do it with let me find
another mob story oh there's this Native
American thing okay let's do it and it's
the same exact exact story over and over
the story seems awesome when people
explain the movie to me I was like I
it's not even that good the story sus
the story is interesting sad bro it's
it's kind of interesting yo Indians find
oil they get [__] white slaves and
they start pimping true story they don't
even get white slaves they're already
kind of dominated while you're there I
want to see that part they kind of had
white SL son when did you see it I
having a white Butler that's a slave did
you that's as far as y'all will ever get
to
slay
as go but we the
original I wish they spent more time on
that relationship from the beginning
there's this whole thing about how they
can't get their own money out of the
bank because the bank is trying to
protect them like there's already the
restrictions you don't for me and who am
I to criticize coresi but like for me I
wish they built up the the the wealth
the money the exu what is it called
exuberance what is the word I'm looking
for the lavishness the poppycock of the
natives like they did it with little
montages but they didn't really show it
every every time you're talking to them
they're kind of take advantage of or
struggling or manipulated in some way
they don't have any control glorious
bastards but with Native Americans
you're not going to get it in this movie
that's my favorite thing about Tarantino
people hate that he changes history and
I'm like he changes it so much more sick
would you love everybody changes history
that's the thing like historians change
history he'll change the ending of how
Hitler died or the Manson Murders but
I'm like I love seeing that my boy
that's what they do but I heard with SCA
because you didn't like it he tried to
stay as accurate to the times as make it
awesome that's why if I wanted accuracy
I would just go read about it yeah I
want a movie I thought it entertaining
it could have been shorter but I did
think it was good it was going to be
longer oh he so he did see it what else
would they I thought you just arguing
having nothing no no no I saw it first
respectable I thought you doing a Mark I
mean there it was just so like some gay
ass [__] at the end when he gives the
speech about what happens he just didn't
like it cuz white people look bad in
this that's
I thought we look good oh yeah yeah we
gave them all this oil bro come on I
thought we look good like we were just
stealing the Indian girls Indian dudes
no game limp
dicks also their commitment to blankets
is unbelievable like you would think
that they would move to another
apparatus to keep them warm after what
happened with the blankets there's not a
scene where they're not wrapped in a
[__] blanket yeah it's almost to the
point where I started to feel a little V
that's their vaccine bro that's how they
are now not D now they're IM ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like now yeah like now kids got a bunch
of [__] now kids got all these like
new diseases yeah because they were uh
kept away from each other for three
years so now they're like okay do we
vaccinate them so that they don't get
sick with these new diseases and then
run the risk of what happens with the
vaccine potentially or do we just let
them go play with each other and hope
they can beat whatever illness they'll
get yeah that's what you do but that's a
real thing yeah is that wild yeah kind
of insane I want to hear what tell me
why you liked it and won't come at it uh
through judgment I genuinely Maybe I'm
Wrong so break down well one it was a
story I wasn't familiar with so that was
cool I read the book so maybe that
changes things ah so you might be
judging the book to the movie yeah
usually usually everyone I mean I'll be
honest with you I read three pages from
the book no but he read but you did read
it I read three pages of it so no I read
a little I read a little bit of the book
and then yeah three P I just thought it
was good like it it had a nice little
twist I thought um the guy was good in
the er's character was good yeah a
little bit like I learned very quick but
my shorty knew it immediately and I was
like oh [__] I didn't pick up on that
immediately you thought the guy who
referred to himself as king I thought he
was just trying to son his his nephew
you know be like yo you call me King
[__] this autism autism movie reviews
is awesome you just watching stuff being
like dude I think this Hitler guy might
be up to something bad he was he was
good I'll give Leo credit here and I'll
give SC I thought Leo could have started
out good as well what what's that I
thought Leo started out good as well but
I think he was using them from the
get-go as well just in a different way
not the same that's the thing like and
listen we're going to ruin some stuff I
we don't have to ruin okay can Ru okay
so here's the thing that I liked about
Leo and this is like really good acting
really good directing it's hard to have
an absolutely abhorent evil character it
like he does some of the most evil
things that humans have ever done to one
another it's like disgusting what he's
doing and you're not rooting for him but
like you're almost empathizing with him
a little bit it's like he's stupid it
did you that's what okay you looked at
that as he was dumb yeah I think he's
like hey I'm so ignorant where it's like
even though I'm being selfish it's
almost like I'm kind of like giving you
a little leeway just because you're just
so dumb like that's interesting so you
okay I looked at him as a kind of like
shrewd smart character that was afraid
of his uncle and really wanted success
and
he was willing to sacrifice everybody
but I don't think he would be willing to
fully sacrifice his
wife but it's interesting at the end
there's that scene [__] it because he
knew what he was doing to his wife that
whole time exactly but and then she
would have forgiven him if it felt like
there's the last scene where she goes
well she because there's before that
there's a scene he does a bunch of
[__] up [__] right like he's
responsible for like he Partners up and
basically is killing her family members
they're white guys that try to marry the
oages they're Native Americans and then
they get the land rights and if the
women die all of a sudden the land
rights are transferred back right and
this is all like a diabolical plot from
another dude who's the uncle character
and so he comes in but it seems like he
actually does really like his wife but
he's involved somewhat in the murder of
the family and all these people around
him so and he's like giving his wife
this like diabetes medication because
all the Native Americans are eating like
white people they're eating bacon and
candy and [__] and they all die at 50
from diabetes they just metabolism there
you go
and uh so there's a moment
where
she she is a conversation with him she's
like we'll we'll we'll reveal all of our
secrets we'll put them in a box and
we'll throw it in the river
metaphorically speaking like let's get
it all out cuz I think we can move past
it he ends up going against his uncle
putting his uncle away testifying
against and putting his uncle away and
there's some justice for the family for
the O tribe and then she asks him what
were you giving me the insul and he goes
uh it was just insulin and then she just
freezes up and walks out and the whole
time she knows that he's been probably
involved in the murder of her her family
and all these things she it looked like
she was ready to forgive yeah I think so
but that's the natives they're good
forgiving people so that I thought
that's what scorsi was trying to show
like these people are so forgiving if
you just acknowledge what the [__] has
been done they will potentially move on
mhm but not even acknowledging what has
happened to them they have to be like
[__] you MH I wonder if that's messaging
all right guys we're going to take a
break for a second you already see the
lights you know what time it is hard
dick is hard dick season okay Four
Seasons a year is hard dick season and
blue Chu is going to bring it to you
same active ingredient that's inside
viagara seal but this is The Chew it's
the one we rock with and this is the one
that you're breaking backs and snapping
spines with okay I'm telling you you
chew it up chew it out simple as that
and you know what you're going to get
your first month free all you got to do
is pay $5 shipping when you go to
blue.com and use the promo code flagrant
okay that's it right there all you got
to do is pay the $5 shipping and you
going to get that first month for free
blu.com promo code flagrant get after it
now let's get back to the show why' you
think it was a bad movie three and a
half hours if that movie is 1 hour 45
minutes or two hours and listen score
like the shots are beautiful the
lighting is I took a little catnap in
between you know thank you that's all
I'm saying you got it that's all I'm
saying also I'm an adult son I was at
the ey pick I had food oh yeah you get
too comfy and [__] like that come on
dude I'm I'm already leaned up take a on
that somebody told me I think this movie
would have done well on Netflix cuz
people told me about the Irishman
remember that was three and a half hours
people were like yo break it into 45
minute chunks so people who told me it
sucked usually watch the whole thing
through I would just like press pause
whenever I was like all right I'm going
to come back and revisit it like I it's
a series I like the Irish though yeah
but that's a really good point you
cannot do that at the movie theater and
directors got to know that yeah don't
have us sitting here for three and a
half hours if you don't got three and a
half hours of heat yeah that's what
81-year-old soresi he's delivered enough
greatness to do that and by the way he's
also done other things outside the mafia
realm like not lately like avator
Shutter Island I thought he didn't do
aviator I thought that was the other
director
no sh Shutter Island so uh what's it
called Wolf Wall Street that's kind of
no W wall stre was so amazing he's on
Leo's jock bro there's there's a new
commercial of like with Leo and dairo
competing like I think done five movies
with him Dao's done like eight and
they're competing over who he likes more
but Leo went to another director that
his that Hispanic dude and got his Oscar
he had to leave Scorsese to go get his
Oscar SC don't get Oscars he got one for
the Departed and I actually didn't love
The Departed bro The Departed was
fantastic I thought the ending was just
so like phenomenal crazy you can't trust
him in food or
movies
part I'll say this and and then I
thought I might have just been mad at
the ending cuz if you haven't seen it by
now that's on you everyone dies I was
just like yo give me one person living
yeah everyone dies and I was just like
this is like comical it is frustrating
I'll give you that I think it's bad this
is what Leo did really well in departed
is uh that sustained
anxiety like oh yeah Le was amazing you
could
feel like he'd been in that pressure
cooker for a while yeah and I thought he
did that in this in this one as well
like that cup you interviewed oh yeah
where talking about like he's just
always in it like he was actually happy
when he went to prison you relieved
right bro he said he' drive down the
highway and he would just feel his body
go numb he would just have like moments
of paralysis of just like anxiety [__]
with his heart and his [__] leg would
go numb what the [__] he' be like I'm
going to drive in this Lane that way if
I pass out I'll hit the g the context of
what you're talking about this a cop of
the 75th precinct they had a documentary
called the 75 and he was basically
that's in New York City yeah yeah it's
in Brooklyn and he basically was like a
crooked cop that teamed up with a drug
dealer to like shake down drug dealers
confiscate their Drugs sell the drugs to
different drug dealers and then if like
he was paying people were paying him for
protection on the Block and if they
wouldn't pay he would go and [__] him up
and he was living this double life and
it stressed him out so much he was like
just constantly anxious and the second
he got arrested he was like oh thank God
what's his name Mike Dow so Mike D yeah
so go there's the episode's out now but
it's the same thing it's like just
Perpetual anxiety for like 10 years it's
like uncut gems like bro another great
one good good time all the safty [__] is
like that but Leo's nice bro Leo is [__]
nice incredible and it's interesting to
see him get older looking like
specifically in this movie like early
Leo is heartthrob yeah and now you're
looking at him you're like oh you're
like an adult like you have wrinkles
like he's not one of these Hollywood
actors that they just have botoxed their
face point they aging at
all have like huge access to to
beautifying Tech like where they're like
uh approvals for that I mean big with
actresses what do you mean like the
anti-aging stuff antiaging like a lot of
that he looks like he's just like make
me look as real as possible dude it
works because if you are that like
perfect
pristine face and skin like no wrinkles
no character how can how can you play a
character that's as anxious and [__] you
seen that video with the guy that tries
to surprise his wife and she's so booxed
out like he he scares her and her
reaction her face doesn't move she just
goes literally have you haven't seen
this no get this out keep going I'll
find it yeah it's interesting I wonder
if that like affects certain actors like
there's there's certain people um what's
the guy's name who plays a Hulk in The
Avengers oh Mark Ruffalo Mark Ruffalo
like his his teeth are kind of stained
like he's disheveled but to me that
lends itself to him playing a character
that is a normal person people who are
real actors and want to be character
actors they age they don't give a [__]
it all lends itself to whatever but they
want to play the weird guy they don't
need to play the hard throb so different
between men and women and character
actor that's true ain't no ain't no
woman allowing herself to just fall the
[__] off I think we we only give that to
Baby marrow Street anybody else y you
better be hot
for the most part yeah but there's a
couple but yeah men who don't like Tom
Cruz all like jokes aside he needs to be
the leading man he can't not be the face
of a franchise he needs to do all that
[__] Leo seems like I will [__] whoever
I want to no matter how I look I want to
do cool projects that's what I want to
do and I'm going to be a leading man but
cool characters there's this character
in
it and he's I think one of the I think
he's one of the best actors alive today
his name is I think Jesse plens oh he's
so good that's Landry from uh Landry
from Friday Night Lights oh yeah what
happened to his face though so I think
he's just fluctuated in weight and I
don't think he has great skin meth Damon
meth Damon yeah breaking B that's what
they called him yeah he's [__] from
Friday Night Lights to how he looks now
is but now he got skinny I think he got
onic and he like lost all the weight but
he was also in uh breaking bad but like
he's he's an amazing act oh my God he's
one that even for Friday Night Lights he
was still that dude on that in the
future he's like character actor great
call he was in ince Judas and the black
Messi Irishman he does this thing that I
admire so much with with actors which is
he's patient he doesn't like some actors
I feel like when they come on to their
scene they feel like they have to make
it the biggest [__] scene and they
have to go crazy I think that's a we're
maybe a little bit more impulsive when
it comes to that cuz we're a reaction
the Jesse plens guy if he knows that his
character has an arc that's going to
change he's like soft chill like relaxed
in the beginning like it's almost like I
don't even care how this Scene goes I'm
timid I'm easy yeah and then when his
character goes evil MH it is you built
up so much currency yeah about us
thinking that you're someone not even to
pay attention to that when the flip
comes we feel like we've been completely
Li to like and and to have the patience
that was Breaking Bad it was Haunting
how evil he was and how even when he was
evil he was very selfs spoken about it
almost like but you need to build kind
about how evil he was it was crazy I I
don't think you've seen it but you I
assume have yeah I mean just it's just a
ballsy move yeah it's it's it's a ballsy
[__] move to go out there for the
first few scenes and just be like really
kind of like shy and kind of easy that
like stayed in my bones the way he how
much is that his director how much is
his actor I've seen him do it so many
times that I'm giving him credit for it
but I imagine directors now see it and
they go we need that hey can you just
turn it down to two out of 10 cu I'm
going to let you [__]
rip here but just let's take it and it
also seems to me as someone who's really
aware of the story if you're one of
these guys who's like a day player
you're coming in you got your lines
you're not even thinking how this could
affect what you're filming 2 weeks from
now yeah that's not going to happen but
if you're in there going oh I know in
two weeks we have this scene and I'm
going to set that scene up now I'm going
to make you love me I'm going to make
you feel bad for me you're going to
probably think I'm a little stupid
that's what you think in Breaking B he's
a little stupid question uh daero or
Samuel L Jackson CU I feel like they're
both always daero and Samuel L in their
scenes but they're still good actors but
dairo I think old dairo like the movie
now if you rewatch it it seems so slow
but Taxi Driver whatever it's called he
he plays a Madman deer hunter or
whatever it's called go to some of
Samuel like really did some [__] give me
your Sam go go go sorry through the 90s
early dairo was like the character actor
that always played a completely
different guy I think I'm pretty sure
that was a perception then when he got
older he's a star I'm not going to keep
doing that but 15 years of dairo playing
roles that are just like yo this guy's a
[__] madman or a hooligan and he's in
that character what's what's the
argument for I think Samuel's beloved
yeah I think I'm just thinking about
them now but like early Korea you would
have to give it to Da just because he
has more range whereas like Samuel I
feel like has become like this beloved
Arch type like I'm going to see Samuel
as Samuel I'm whoever the patch guy he
plays in Avengers what's his name Nick
Fury Nick Fury he don't play Nick Fury
yeah that guy's name is Samuel with an
ey patch with an i patch on Samuel is on
the plane when he's in Star Samuel dero
now though Dao now like now like even in
this movie it's like he's talking like
Dao yo he kind of like goes in and out
of the accent that's what I'm saying he
[__] up sometimes and I'm like oh okay
okay that's a fair assessment can we
look up early dairo Ro sorry I know
you're looking up Samuel L but early
dairo roles like Raging Bull I've seen
parts of it and it's just like yo this
guy is he he's playing a boxer with CTE
who beats [__] Godfather Part Two is
phenomenal Godfather part two very soft
spoken whatever you got to give it to
Dao but Mean Streets
tax driver Deer Hunter Raging Bull king
of
comedy Once Upon a Time in America sorry
just interrupt king of comedy he plays
that's what the Joker is based on
Phoenix's Joker is based on king of
comedy so he plays that that's why they
put him in Joker it's like this
character is kind of based on you so
let's put you in Joker uh K fear he
plays a [__] madman uh dear Deer
Hunter I think phenomenal Casino
phenomenal these are phenomenal but I
would say these are dairo doing what we
know
but yeah before that dude dairo was a
guy that was playing everything and you
were like whoa let's pull up uh Samuel
cuz I feel like we're not doing him
Justice cuz he does so many [__]
roles Tarantino is like Samuel Jackson
is his favorite actor to work with one
of them he loves Samuel L you ever hear
Samuel L wanted a purple lightsaber in
Star Wars so you could see him on screen
they don't have purple ice saers and he
went to George Lucas and he goes look
bro if you want me in this movie I want
to be in this movie I know you want me
but you got to let me get I got to get a
swaggy lightsaber and they were like all
right I love did they actually give it
to love that what do he in Eddie Murphy
wrw must have been a sketch early on or
something John kelor that's crazy uh
Eddie Murphy hooked him up he's didn't
Coming to America remember he sticks up
the MD he was good yeah anybody moves I
blow your [__] head off uh Mo Blues I
don't remember him good Fellas I don't
remember him in that Jurassic Park
jungle fever I barely remember him he's
in Jurassic Park he's the IT guy who
smoked cigarettes um yeah yeah yeah Pulp
Fiction was really good unbelievable
Pulp Fiction I think was his breakout
role that's when you were like oh this
guy yeah that's unbelievable but he's
still kind of doing Samuel L yeah I see
that okay oh
sphere sphere was cool sphere was a cool
movie The Incredibles oh he's Frozone
yeah you know he's
Frozone
super I loved him just die hard him and
Bruce Willis was
oh Die Hard with a Vengeance he was
great and he wasn't really Samuel L I
don't think he was a soft spoken guy
who's number one who's number one actor
alive alive alive that if he if he
wanted to act more it's Daniel D Lewis
baby oh yeah yeah yeah I'm like n no
yeah give him too much credit I'm I
think he's really good good but I think
he's like really good but he he doesn't
make never made me cry yeah I've never
like fallen in love with this guy no
okay that's fair but he becomes whatever
the [__] he's doing becomes that good
for you yeah for you best favorite Jim
car best favorite yeah Tom Hanks
is Tom Hanks is favorite yeah Tom
Hanks um I personally like
Cumberbatch I've SE not old enough
Yetman was up there for me Pacino dairo
widely regarded as one two I think you
got to put Leo up there Chino kind of
fell off for me he did but I think they
all but Chino's how old now they're old
they're old I'm just saying right now
what do we got Leo might be the guy
right now I put cumber bch Denzel who
Denzel was my number one and now I feel
like it's like action movies more so but
he had a run you still got to put him in
there though he's my number one but what
was the last movie of his where you were
like Blown Away by his performance don't
just say every movie [__] I see every
Denzel movie it's been a while yeah I
saw the one based on the book cuz he's
now doing
equalizer he directed Anar I thought
equalizer was good maybe but you didn't
see it fences I saw fences I saw it yeah
I saw it I that's how much I love Denzel
I saw fences yeah I did like I but he
hasn't done anything it was good it was
fine you know was he in like HL or some
[__] like that mcth aell or mcth I saw
that [__] black and white it was weird
as [__] but I saw that I went to
Angelica that who's number one um who's
the P Ant-Man I really like him Paul but
he's not number one number one he just
has range I like
is always you get me serious and you get
me funny let me give you somebody who's
going to be so [__] unbelievably good
it's crazy he's the guy who played The
Joker briefly in the last Batman movie
you just see him in the jail cell he's
in like the the the B the Banshees of
insuran or something like that Paul Doo
no Paul no no no no that's scarecrow
Barry Keegan that [__] oh [__]
he was going to come to your um your
London show get out of here yeah he
would he is so very
kogan he's good he's good oh my God he's
good I don't know him this guy is GNA be
I mean obviously he needs to get lucky
with roles but like meaning like he
needs to have an impactful performance
in a movie that also is huge but you
can't take your eyes off him when he's
on screen it's like it's one of the most
magnetic things I've ever seen in my
entire life you know what we should give
actors credit for as much as we should
on them the Joker killed Heath Ledger
the like as far as we know and every
actor is like I need to play The Joker
oh yeah they're all
psychopath these guys want it dude they
won't kill me yeah they want it I want
to do that thing to get me notoriety
even if it kills me yeah watch Dark
Knight the other day because of that
he's incredible it's crazy some movie
like somebody ranked The Jokers and they
put him as number one overw Walken and
they just they said he was mesmerizing
on screen and you really are like when
he's on screen you're like I can't look
at anything else in the
he is number one overw it's not even
it's clearly it's clearly you could join
the [__] Army at
patreon.com flagrant